in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Sean
and Jennifer are with us welcome guys
how are ya good are you thank you
welcome we're so glad you're here and
your son's name is what ty ty at how old
is ty seven and a half five and a half
very cool and you guys are here to do
your debt-free scream yes sir where are
you from Sarasota Florida but and
welcome to Nashville and how much debt
have you paid off about a hundred and
one thousand dollars awesome and how
long did that take roughly thirty eight
months cool
making what kind of money during that
time we started about eighty four
thousand and ended up just over a little
bit over one hundred excellent very cool
what do you guys do for a living I'm a
police officer I'm a teacher oh very
cool very cool
perfect so what kind of debt was the
hundred and one thousand it was our
house oh you bet off your house yeah you
guys are young for a paid-for house
you're officially weird yeah I paid for
house you remember mortgage no sir I'm
looking at where people I see weird
people I love it
very cool so what's this house worth
about 270 280 Wow and how old are you
guys 37 man I mean did you ever think
you'd have a paid-for house most people
think they're gonna have a mortgage
their whole lives it was we were able to
set a goal enough that we knew we could
accomplish it so at the end yeah it was
uh everyday we I posted something on the
board on our own refrigerator with
little magnets but kids have and
everyday I had to when I you know we
would go and dinner anything to get from
the refrigerator we would see that and
it actually drove me crazy I love it I
love it so you were on man on a mission
then yeah if we treated uh baby step six
like these like maybe step two
yeah there's a visual intensity yep so
very cool but how long have you guys
been married 13 years 13 years so what
happened 38 months ago that flipped this
switch I was about your journey here I
was at work with a friend of mine Steve
he we were talking about money and
finances and he suggested uh for me to
read this book and I was a little
hesitant at first and I've read enough
you know get-rich-quick scheme books
like that and I read it that brought her
home and instantly read it both in a day
I had read the entire book and I often
joked with him we talked now he's
actually washed and it's a joke I'm
saying it's kind of like we have the
answers to the test of life it really is
I read the back of the book yeah yeah so
Total Money Makeover felt that way yes
sir very cool so Jennifer Sean comes
home and he's got another book and
another scheme and what did you say well
he came to me first and just said you
know we need to get on a budget so that
we can pay this house off and I was like
all right there's for me what we need to
do so just like that yeah we've always
lived within our means so it wasn't uh
it wasn't that much of a stretch okay so
no big no big argument about it just
like okay we've had our fair share
arguments okay while you were getting
out of that the budget fights you mean
yes so what was the worst budget fight
Jennifer was over food so Big Sean's
gonna cut the family back on eating come
on man have to feed the kid it's part of
the deal that's great lo we had a huge
fight over food one time I remember we
first got started man she threw the on
food envelope at me and she goes if
you're sad dad goes smart you go shop
for that amount of money I think it's
come to that a couple times oh well
congratulations you guys how does it
feel to not have a house payment I think
we're a little bit in shock yeah we uh
it's phenomenal
but we still want to keep going with it
and obviously retire early
yeah well I mean you're sitting into top
of careers that'll allow you to do that
I mean that's uh and then have an encore
career and do whatever you want to do as
well so that's the goal got a lot of a
lot of opportunity in front of you and
you know if you just take that old house
payment you used to haven't pay it as a
as an investment every month you're
gonna have millions of dollars just from
that as young as you guys are that's
what we've been doing so it's absolutely
fabulous that is so so fun and so
Jennifer when people
we'll find out you paid off your house
and they say how did you do that because
they're in shock it can't be done what
do you tell them the secret to getting
out of debt is just got to get on a
budget and stick to it that's simple
yeah make sure it's a priority yeah a
game plan and stick to the game plan
yeah there's a game plan to it the
paperwork the the numbers yell at you
don't they they tell you what you've got
to do yeah they say don't spend that if
you spend that you can't put it on that
and pretty quickly you go okay three
years we paid off our house yes sir Rox
it's just completely rocks that is
awesome I'm so proud of y'all
congratulation thank you thank you very
well done so has mr. Tye been practicing
his debt-free scream we've been
practicing on the drive up here yes
okay so ty you ready man you know I do
this all right counting on you to go big
does it go big or go home man that's the
day long debt free screams all right
Sean and Jennifer and ty Sarasota
Florida they're so weird their house is
paid for a hundred at 37 years old a
hundred and one thousand paid off in 38
months making 80 for up to a hundred
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream ready 3 2 1
well done great great job
hey you guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
are enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and
did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right it's
kind of better than the dayroom to
channel don't tell them I said that I'm
kidding I'm panic so subscribe and
there's lots of videos about life and
money so while you're at it if you want
to check out a video then you can check
out how to do a monthly budget it's one
of the best videos out there
you